Speaker 1: Let's see if we can
speak to Darrel from Texas. Is
that the right way to say it?
Speaker 7: Daryl Ariel.
Hi, David. This is my first call on the
show. I've been watching your show for
a while. Kind of nervous, but you're doing.
Speaker 1: Great so far. What's on your mind?
Speaker 7: Okay, so I just saw this clip from
MSNBC where, like Mondaire Jones basically talked
about how Democrats should be happy that Trump
has, like a stranglehold over the GOP and Trump
has a real shot of, like, winning or like winning
the GOP nomination. Yeah, and my question to you
would be like, should Democrats like like, should
Democrats have the attitude of like, oh, we should
we should want Trump to be the GOP nominee
because he'd be easier to be in the general?
Speaker 1: I just talked about this with Adam
Schiff earlier this week. Adam I lean more.
I'm more sympathetic to what you're saying
because I think Trump would be easier to beat
and also would be less disastrous if he were
president because the Sanders would get more
done. But I still see Trump as having a really
good shot of winning in 24. Adam Schiff disagreed
with me. I think it's really a matter of opinion.
I don't think there's like an objectively right
answer on this issue because we're estimating
we're making a prediction as to what Trump would
do if he were president four more years from age
78 to 82 or whatever it would be. Right. We're
being forced to say what would happen and based
on what we think would happen, what's better? So
it's a matter of opinion, but I am sympathetic
to the idea that it is better for Democrats to
run against Trump. I could be wrong. We're not
going to know it at minimum. We're not going
to know until it happens. And it may not happen.
Speaker 7: Oh, God. You okay? Yes. I just thought
was interesting to mention, because I remember
during 2016. What, The Hillary campaign. Yep. I
believe they tried like doing like the Pied Piper
strategy where they where like, like they wanted
to push Trump to be the nominee of the expectation
of Trump. Excuse her to be. Right. We all saw.
Speaker 1: It backfires and it
backfired. No, you're right. And
that's something I've brought up also.
Speaker 7: So, yeah. So I just I'm
just worried that Democrats do like
they could get complacent, you know,
and potentially botched it again, like 2016.
Speaker 1: Well, that's the biggest and most
important thing, which is no matter
who is the eventual Republican nominee,
Democrats can always find a way to screw it
up. And that's what should really scare us.
Speaker 7: Just got you. Okay.
Yes, that's my question I just
thought was interesting to bring up.
All right. Thank you for protocol.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Dario from Texas. Great to
hear from you. Let's go to a break. That does it
for calls today. I will take calls again and
I hope to be able to speak to you next time.